Speaker 1: Donald Trump hired a new spokeswoman
a few months ago.
She is dramatically and cartoonishly more
unhinged, I would say, than any of Donald
Trump's former spokespeople.
Her name is Liz Harrington.
She went on Fox News yesterday and she claimed,
listen to this.
She claimed that the Arizona so-called audit
of the twenty twenty election results.
Now, that's the election from nine months
ago.
That's the one, she says that the audit in
Arizona found provisionally two hundred and
seventy five thousand potential fraudulent
ballots.
She also says nearly four thousand were falsely
certified and it's all Trump.
Trump won.
Trump won everything, according to her.
Let's take a look at this clip from Fox News
Speaker 3: that includes the hunting season.
Here we go.
OK, look at the preliminary findings from
the independent audit.
Already we have two hundred and seventy five
thousand potential fraudulent ballots.
Speaker 1: How many caveats are there if you
look at the prelim?
Menary findings preliminary, meaning meaningless
as of yet from the independent, it's not an
independent audit.
It's also not an audit.
There are two hundred and seventy five potential
fraudulent ballots.
Could there be more ifs, ands and buts there?
Guys, I just looked at five potential vacation
homes which have a real preliminary standing
as homes that I might buy.
Do you know what would happen if I showed
up and tried to get into those homes?
The police would be called.
And so the point she wants to make, of course,
is Trump won Arizona.
Let's continue
Speaker 3: this.
One hundred and sixty thousand that were printed
on thin paper outside of the regulations of
Maricopa County is too thin.
Seventy five thousand ballots that were supposed
to be mailed out, but they have no record
of them ever being sent.
You also have 18000 voters who were purged
from the voter rolls and who voted in the
election but were purged after the election.
And here's a significant one, Brett, if I
could bring up that
Speaker 1: everything so far, I guess, is
not significant.
Now, she's going to give us the real significant
stuff
Speaker 3: the county will not touch.
Three thousand nine hundred and eighty one
people voted despite registering after the
October 15th court ordered deadline.
And here's the key question.
That means Maricopa County certified false
results.
And if we still have a free country with one
set of rules for every every American,
Speaker 1: this is a spokeswoman.
So it's bad enough when it's Jenna Ellis or
Sidney Powell or whatever this is.
This is the official spokeswoman for the former
president of the United States, Donald Trump,
nine months after the election talking about
these fraudulent ballot dumps.
Speaker 3: The votes need to be thrown out
immediately.
Or do we live in a communist country?
Can't votes turn out one hundred to nothing?
No, that does not say for Joseph Stalin.
It says for Joseph Biden.
That's in Fulton County, Georgia.
If we're going to keep a country free, we
need to have these audits to get to the bottom
of it, because one hundred to nothing is not
the United States of America.
We need these audits to continue to the true
results.
Speaker 1: We're not completely delusional,
completely delusional.
But the point she wants to make is Trump really
won Arizona.
Remember, the official results in Arizona
are that Joe Biden won, but only by about
11000 votes.
So therefore, you know, if two hundred and
seventy five thousand ballots were really
fraudulent, then Trump would have won Arizona
easily.
That's the point, except it's all completely
made up.
They are potentially fraudulent until they
are verified and they were verified within
a day or two of Election Day.
I actually have a difficult time getting a
read on Liz Harington.
I can't tell if she's a liar or completely
delusional.
Something about how she talks doesn't make
it totally clear to me.
Does she believe this stuff or is she actually
living in a fantasy world, divorced from reality?
Is she going out and saying things she knows
to be lies?
Maybe the two aren't mutually exclusive.
Maybe she's a liar and delusional in some
sense.
But the particularly horrifying part is that
millions of people in the United States believe
this.
There are millions of people in this country
who will watch Fox News and they will hear
Liz Herrington's say, we found on a preliminary
basis two hundred and seventy five thousand
potentially fraudulent votes.
And to them, that means Trump won Arizona
and that Joe Biden stole that period without
question.
End of story.
And so much as is the case with Trump in general,
the fact that Trump existed wouldn't have
meant much if there weren't tens of millions
of people willing to vote for him.
And the fact that Liz Harrington is going
around saying this stuff would mean a lot
less if there weren't tens of millions of
people who believed it.
And it is a really, really ugly situation.
I don't see any way to fix this.
And speaking of things, I don't see any way
how to fix.
We get to today's voicemail.